all right before we go I want to share
something super cute I found scrolling
social media this is what I'm
liking so we talk a lot on this show
about how we can make kids more
interested in Reading that's why I love
what one Milwaukee Teacher is doing to
engage his first grade students he turns
reading and writing into catchy
interactive songs like his beloved
punctuation
chant mark question mark ask the
question ask question how are you how
are you voice lifts up voice lifts up
how are you doing friends how you doing
Exclamation point Exclamation point
strong and Loud strong and Loud hey you
hey you hey you hey
you I love him adorable we have that
educator on the line right now watching
on TMJ4 let's say hi to Jake y'all
what's up
Jake hi how are you I am so good but
first first and foremost thank you so
much for being an educator we appreciate
you so
much value you so how how did you start
with this technique it's very memorable
oh my goodness well thank you honestly
so I am a little bit of an extra person
as you can tell um but honestly I saw a
need for it um you know we see some huge
proficiency problems in America in
Reading
and the research shows us we have to
teach the explicit code the sounds and
the symbols and a lot of people say well
that's boring or that takes the joy away
and so I thought well why don't we add
some motions some songs and some chants
so that it's not boring and then now
here I am I I love you so much oh my
gosh what what did the students parents
think do they get involved because if I
walked into my kids classroom you do I
would join so cuz I'm I'm also extra I
don't know if you know this I I actually
do invite the parents every month to
join in um so they actually do join us
for phonics um every month and they get
to do the lesson along with us but um
honestly Kelly the the sweetest response
I've gotten is from parents all over the
globe and it's been like the
authenticity piece so I don't um look
like a lot of teachers that you would
expect in your brain when you think of
an elementary teacher right I act and
sound a little different and I have so
many messages from parents like thank
you for letting our kids see what
authenticity is and so it's it's been
like unreal I would have never expected
such a outpouring of love from parents
that have kids that maybe feel like they
didn't used to fit in and and they can
be themselves that is beautiful I'm
that's what a what a beautiful purpose
other than the major one you're already
doing like that's incredible I'm glad
that I'm glad that they voiced that as
well because it's very important for
everybody to feel like you know they fit
in somewhere right and you find your
your people so I'm liking your post
right now right yay thank you and that's
not all that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor your truly Unstoppable just Manner
and way you teach it's a very beautiful
thing so what they're going to do is
they're just going to write you a check
for $1,000 how's that
sound thank you so much Jake we love you
and thank you to all our guests this
hour Kelsey gramar Charles mson in and
Ali all have a great day let not try and
change
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home